Salut.
Vous l'avez compris dans le titre,
aujourd'hui, c'est une vidéo
un petit peu Ouf !
Mais avant de lancer cette vidéo,
il faut que je vous raconte la genèse.
En fait, un jour, j'ai rencontré un mec
qui s'appelle Michaël
et c'est un abonné.
Il code des choses...
Il fait des lignes de code
comme ça...
Et moi j'avais besoin de faire
une application pour mon spectacle
Application qui s'appelle :
"Fabien Olicard"
On n'a pas trouvé plus simple.
Et elle sert durant le spectacle.
Durant le spectacle, les spectateurs,
ceux qui sont venus me voir le savent,
on se sert de ça, ça s'appelle
le vibujor
D'ailleurs, petite info,
si vous avez l'application,
ne la désinstallez surtout pas
parce qu'au mois de juin
il y aura une mise à jour,
avec un cadeau pour vous.
Il lit les lignes de codes.
En fait, c'est Matrix,
ce mec c'est Neo.
Il ne le sait pas,
mais c'est Neo.
Bref.
Il m'a proposé, aujourd'hui,
de me montrer qu'il trouvait
un mot de passe plus rapidement que moi.
En clair :
il peut mentaliser un ordinateur.
Il peut mentaliser un mot de passe.
Et moi j'ai dit :  " Ok.
Ben fait moi voir."
Générique.
[Musique Générique]
C'est lui Neo,
c'est lui qui est dans la matrice.
Fab : Ça va Michaël ?
Mic : Salut, ça va ?
Fab : Ouais, c'est cool.
Alors, euh...
Si j'ai bien bien compris,
Fab : Tu as amené un ordi ? On le fait sur mon Mac ?
Mic : Ouais.
Fab : Sur ton ordi ? Peut importe ?
Mic : J'ai amené un ordi.
Fab : Mais peut importe l'ordi, à la base ?
Mic : Absolument.
Fab : Ok.
Mic : On s'en fout complétement.
Fab : Tu es capable de détourner
le mot de passe,
Mic : Exactement.
Fab : C'est çà ?
Fab : Toi, tu n'as pas besoin de mentaliser
quelqu'un pour le trouver dans la tête,
Mic : Ah non, je ne devine pas moi...
Fab : Ok.
Fab : Alors, je te propose que tu nous
le prouves et après que tu nous l'expliques.
Mic : Ça marche
Fav : Je vais moi-même mettre
un mot de passe sur ta bécane,
Mic : Ok.
Fab : Et après, t'essayes de rentrer dedans.
Fab : Ça roule ?
[Musique]
Fab : Je tape le mot de passe que je veux, moi ?
Mic : Absolument.
Fab : Donc tu regardes chez ta mère. Là-bas.
Mic : Ok. Pardon.
[Rires]
Fab : Tu sais quoi ? J'espère sincèrement
que ta technique est bonne
parce que j'ai tapé n'importe quoi,
donc je ne sais pas ce que j'ai mis.
Mic : Ok.
Fab : Voilà. Donc ça, c'est fait.
Mic : Ça marche.
Fab : Maintenant, je vais tourner la caméra,
euh... à partir de quand je peux te
filmer faire ?
Fab : Est-ce que tu as besoin d'une zone secrète ?
Mic : Absolument.
Mic : Je vais me retirer
[Éclat de rire de Fabien]
Mic : et faire des manipulations.
Mic : sur...       sur l'ordinateur.
Fab : Ok. Ça marche.
Fab : Euh... Et bien, retire-toi, pendant
ce temps-là je vais parler, euh...
Mic : Très bien.
Fab : à ces personnes...
Par contre, je vais mettre un petit
compteur juste là, là !
Ici là, par là, autour de moi.
Enfin, je vais mettre un compteur quelque part,
et je vous dirai combien de temps il s'est
retiré, comme il l'a si joliment dit.
Si toi aussi ce mot t'a choqué
tu peux mettre un #choquéetdéçu
dans l'espace commentaires.
Bon. En tout cas, je ne doute pas
qu'il soit capable de le faire,
par contre j'ai hâte de savoir
comment il va faire.
Et si c'est facilement faisable
ou pas, en fait.
Parce que c'est ça, en fait,
avec les génies,
c'est à dire que lui,
ça peut lui paraître simple,
et nous, on peut ne rien comprendre...
Mais je trouve ça dingue
qu'il arrive à passer le mot de passe de base
sur les ordis normaux et sur les mac...
Fab :  Tu as déjà fini ?      C'est vrai ?
Mic : Oui.
Fab : Donc là, on est sur l'écran d'accueil.
Mic : Absolument.
Fab : Vas-y. Tape le mot de passe.
Fab : C'est une arnaque parce qu'il
n'y avait pas que 3 trucs
Fab : Oh pu****
Fab : Tu rentres dedans...
Mic [ironique] : Mais !?
Mic : Mais qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Fab : Donc en fait, c'est avec un mot de passe
en 3 caractères que tu as pu rentrer ?
Mic : Absolument. Je peux le refaire
avec 12, si tu veux...
Fab : Ouais, vas-y, attends 'tends 'tends,
je veux le revoir avec, euh...
avec 7 caractères !
Mic : Sept ?
Fab : Vas-y.
Fab : En fait tu tapes littéralement
n'importe quoi là ?
Mic : Je ne sais pas...
Mic : Peut-être...
[Éclat de rire de Fabien]
Mic : Ta da !
Fab : J'essaye, moi aussi.
A...bo... nnez... vous... je...rends
Fab : Abonnez-vous je rends.
Et là tu n'as rien débranché, là ?
Mic : Non, absolument rien.
Fab : Il n'y a rien à l'intérieur ?
Mic : Il n'y a rien. Il est comme tout à l'heure
c'est le même ordi.
Fab : Tu n'as pas installé un programme, euh...
Mic : Non.
Mic : Absolument pas.
Fab : Tu n'as pas eu besoin d'être connecté à Internet,
Fab : parce que tu n'as pas mon
mot de passe WiFi.
Fab : Sauf si tu avais un partage de connexion.
Fab : Non ? Même pas ?
Mic : Non, rien. Rien !
Fab : Genre, si tu es dans un grand magasin,
Fab : tu es à Carrefour...
Mic : Absolument.
Mic : Je peux faire la même chose
avec tous les ordis.
Fab : Et les Mac aussi.
Mic : Les Mac aussi, ouais.
Mic : Exactement.
Fab : C'est... incroyable...
Fab : Donc, en clair, déjà, ce que tu es
en train de me dire, c'est que
le mot de passe de la page d'accueil
ça ne sert à rien !
Mic : A que dalle !
[Éclat de rire de Fabien]
Mic : C'est... laisse tomber.
Fab : Que ce soit bien clair. D'accord.
Fab : Ok.
Mic : J'espère que tu n'as rien à cacher,
par exemple là, sur ton ordi,
tu vois ?
Fab : Nooon ! Non, bien sûr que non ! Non, non.
[Rire de Michaël]
Fab : Par contre, je peux effacer
des choses à distance...
Fab : Explications.
Mic: On va utiliser un outil qui est régulièrement
utilisé par les mecs qui ont des petits magasins
euh... des petits magasins
d'informatique.
Et, en fait, c'est tout simplement
sur une clef USB que je l'ai mis
c'est un petit logiciel en fait.
Alors, ce n'est pas un logiciel classique,
dans le sens où il ne va pas s'exécuter
sur un système d'exploitation démaré,
En fait, ça s'appelle un BootKit.
C'est à dire que ça s'exécute
juste avant le système d'exploitation
et en gros ça va, au moment où le
système d'exploitation est copié en mémoire vive,
au tout début en fait,
et bien ça va exécuter des choses dessus,
de sorte que, moi, quand je me connecte,
tout simplement, le mot de passe
n'a plus d'importance,
il est, de toutes façons, valide.
On peut voir le petit chargement,
il est en train de charger Windows.
Et... et voilà, à partir de ce moment là
euh.. c'est fait.
J'ai dit, tout à l'heure, qu'il suffisait
d'une chaîne vide ; on va voir si ça marche...
Et voilà...
Mic : C'est en train de...
Fab : Et c'est Ouf !
Fab : Et donc à chaque fois,
quand il se met en veille,
Fab : en fait, ça fonctionne toujours ?
Mic : Absolument.
Fab : Même s'il n'y a plus la clef ?
Mic : Là, je retire la clef.
Fab : Tu ne l'avais pas la clef tout à l'heure ?
Mic : Ouais, tout à l'heure il n'y avait pas de clef
donc voilà, la clef, elle est juste là
au démarrage.
En fait, ce qui est le plus hallucinant
avec ce truc,
c'est que ça se fait en mémoire vive
c'est à dire que, à partir du moment
où je redémarre l'ordi,
il n'y a plus aucune trace
de mon passage en fait.
[Fab] En tout cas, il n'y aura pas de traces
que toi tu sois passé.
Mic : Exactement. J'ai le temps de faire
plein de choses et toi tu ne le sauras jamais.
[Fab] Tu me fais peur mec.
Je n'irai jamais aux toilettes quand tu es chez moi.
[Fab] J'ai trop peur de te laisser
30 secondes avec mon ordi.
[Fab] Qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
protéger mon ordi qui reste toujours en veille ?
Mic : Alors, malheureusement, il n'y a
pas beaucoup de solutions...
[Fab - Plaisantant] Il n'y en a pas...
Mic : Il y en a. Il y en a.
Mic : Il y en a mais... enfin...
de base, il faut être prudent.
mais euh... une solution serait
de chiffrer entièrement le disque dur.
Alors, tu as des logiciels qui
sont fait pour ça
maintenant, ce n'est vraiment
pas très compliqué à faire.
[Fab] Si mon disque dur est chiffré,
que toi, tu arrives chez moi
avec ta petite clef, euh...
[Mic] Je ne peux rien faire.
[Fab] ...petite clef de bâtard !
Hein ? On va l'appeler comme ça
ta clef.
Et que tu mets dedans, ça va être quoi
la différence par rapport à là, tout de suite ?
Mic : La différence, c'est qu'il ne va pas
être capable...
là, tout de suite, actuellement la clef est capable de modifier le code de démarrage
est capable de faire l'opération qui
me permet, à moi, d'accéder à ton ordi.
[Mic] Elle ne va tout simplement rien pouvoir faire.
[Fab] Oui, parce qu'elle ne parlera pas la même langue...
[Mic] Ouais, voilà. C'est un peu comme
si c'étaient deux langues différentes,
[Fab] Ouais.
[Mic] et... voilà.
[Fab] D'accord. Donc chiffrez vos
disques dur. Chiffrez les. Chiffrez les.
Moi je vais mettre un boulier
à côté du mien.
Au tout départ, cette vidéo on devait
la faire sur ta chaîne,
tu m'as proposé de la faire
sur ta chaîne.
[Mic] Exactement.
Et moi je me suis dit : c'est tellement cool
qu'on pourrait très bien le faire sur la mienne
et ça vous permet de rencontrer
Michaël.
Et, vous vous souvenez ?
J'ai eu, au mois de décembre,
Amixem qui avait dit :
"Faites un raid sur la chaîne de Fabien"
et vous êtes arrivés là.
Et bien, si vous voulez,
faites un raid sur la chaîne de
Michaël
parce que toutes les vidéos qu'il sort,
elles me font halluciner.
Moi j'avais vu la toute première,
c'est quand tu hackais les mecs du Bon Coin.
[Mic] Ouais.
[Fab] Enfin les... les...
[Mic] Les arnaqueurs !
[Fab] Les ARNAQUEURS du Bon Coin.
[Mic] Les méchants arnaqueurs.
[Fab] Mais oui, mais ça c'était Ouf !
Comme d'habitude, si ça vous a plu,
mettez vraiment un pouce en l'air
je crois que ça,
ça le mérite
Vous pouvez également vous abonner
à ma chaîne,
à celle de Michaël
foncez dessus,
et on se donne rendez-vous
samedi matin
à 11h. Ouais, j'ai décidé, ce sera
samedi à 11h la prochaine.
Ciao.
[Musique générique de fin]